so it puts the human in the seat of
fixing
issues
versus writing from scratch do you find
that kind of idea at all interesting
every year we're going to be losing more
and more
control over what machines are doing and
people are saying well it seemed to like
when i was a professor at caltech
uh in this in the 60s we had this
this guy who
who talked a good game
he could give inspiring lectures and
you'd think well
certainly things he was talking about an
hour later you say well what did he say
um
but but but he really felt that it
didn't matter whether computers got the
right answer or not it doesn't matter
whether it made you happy or not in
other words if you you know if if
if if your boss paid for it uh
you know then you had a job you could
you know you could you could take care
of your wife well happiness is more
important than truth
exactly he didn't believe in truth but
he was a philosopher
i like it
and somehow you you see uh
we're going that way i mean
so many more things are are taken over
by saying well this seems to work
and so and when there's
when there's uh competing interests
involved
neither side understands
while the decision is being made
uh
uh it uh
you know we realized now that it's that
is bad but but consider what happens
five five year ten years you're down the
line
when things get even more
further detached and each thing is based
on
something
from the previous year yeah so you start
to lose the more you automate it the
more you start to lose track of uh some
deals
exponentially but so that's the dark
side the positive side is
the more you automate the more you let
humans do what humans do best
so maybe programming
this you know maybe
humans should focus on a small part of
programming that requires that genius
the magic of the human mind
and the mess you let the machine
generate
yeah i mean there that's that's the
positive but of course it does come with
the darkness like
automation
what what's better correct i'm never
going to try to write a book about that
i'm never going to recommend to any of
my students to work for them
you're you're on the side of it i'm on
the side i'm on the side of under
happiness understanding i understand
and i i think these things are really
marvelous if they if
if what they do is you know
all of a sudden we have a better medical
diagnosis or or or you know it will help
guide some scientific experiment or
something like this
you know so you know curing diseases or
what
whatever but
but when it when when it affects
people's lives in a serious way uh uh
so if you're writing if you're writing
code for geeky oh yeah here this is
great
this will make a slaughter bot okay
so i see so
you have to be very careful
like right now it seems like fun and
games it's useful to write a little
javascript program that helps you with
the website
but like you said one year passes two
years passes five years and you forget
you start building on top of it and then
all of a sudden you have autonomous
weapon systems
based
well we're all dead
it doesn't matter in that sense
well in the end
the this whole thing ends anyway so
um but it it pays there is a heat death
of the universe
predicted but i i'm trying to postpone
that for for a little bit
well it'd be nice that at the end as we
approach the heat death of the universe
there is
still some kind of consciousness there
to
to to appreciate it hopefully human
consciousness
i'll settle for 10 to the 10 to the 10
to the 10th year some finite number but
but
things like this might be the reason we
don't pick up any
signals from
extraterrestrial
they don't want anything to do with us
oh because they because they they they
invented it too and
so you you do have a little bit of worry
on the
existential threats of
ai and automation
so like like removing the human from the
picture et cetera yeah
people have more more potential
to do harm now than by far than they did
a hundred years ago
but are you optimistic about so the
humans
are good at creating destructive things
but also humans are good at solving
problems yeah i mean there's half empty
and have full you know that so
we have full or what i can go yeah
so let me let me put it this way because
because it's the only way i can be
optimistic but but
but think of um
of uh
things that have changed because of
civilization
you know they don't occur just in nature
so just
uh just imagine the room we're in for
example
okay some you know we've got
pencils we've got books we've got tables
we've got microphones
clothing food
all these things were added
somebody invented them one by one and
millions of things
uh that we inherit okay um and uh
it's inconceivable that that so many
millions of billions of things wouldn't
have problems and
we would get it all right
um and and each one
would have no negative
effects and so on so it's very amazing
that it much works as does work
you